the TV series based on the works of
Stephen King are a mixed bag some are
incredible others not so much so which
ones are worth watching we're leaving
out some big ones here counting only the
TV series or miniseries with three or
more installments with that in mind
here's every Stephen King TV series
ranked from worst to best Stephen King
has long been outspoken of his contempt
for Stanley Kubrick's 1980 adaptation of
The Shining in 2014 he told Rolling
Stone that he considered it not only a
terrible adaptation but a bad movie in
general he explained obviously people
love it and they don't understand why I
don't the book is hot and the movie is
cold the book ends in fire and the movie
in Ice King took particular aim at how
the movie adapted the Wendy character
played with desperate intensity by
Shelley Duvall the writer said of her
portrayal it's so misogynistic
I mean Wendy Torrance is just presented
as the sort of screaming dishrag
Kubrick's adaptation of The Shining
wouldn't be the last 17 years later ABC
released a three Episode miniseries
version of the story starring Stephen
Webber and Rebecca De Mornay over four
and a half hours King was finally able
to give audiences the story he always
wanted to see on screen while it was
reviewed well at the time the years
haven't been very kind to it
[Music]
turns out four and a half hours is far
too much for this particular King story
the series drags feeling bloated to fill
time and Webber place crazy in a way
that's more goofy than frightening the
whole thing plays out like an
overcorrection and it winds up being far
worse than anything Kubrick could have
ever produced the 2002 series rose-red
revolves around a dormant haunted
Seattle mansion psychology professor
Joyce Reardon brings in an unsuspecting
group of would-be psychics to serve as
bait for the house so she can somehow
get back at her department chair for
taking her tenure aside from the house
itself which makes for a decent horror
backdrop everything else about rose-red
Falls totally flat too much time is
wasted on wandering about aimlessly
calling out to each other and well
wandering some more the characters are
all awful stereotypes and Nancy Travis
is horribly miscast as Joyce on all this
miniseries feels more like a wilted rose
than a red one Stephen King's golden
years was actually the first original
piece of work the author created for TV
airing on CBS in 1991 the series
centered around Harlan Williams a
janitor in his 70s who has given strange
powers after a lab experiment goes awry
Harlan is doused in chemicals that not
only reverses aging but in later
episodes given powers that affect the
world around him in spite of it's
supernatural overtones golden years
winds up playing out a lot like a
typical political thriller the onset of
Harlan's powers means that he has to
keep hidden from government agents who
worry their top-secret experiments will
somehow be exposed Harlan is a threat so
he has to figure out not only how to
keep the agency bad guys off his tail
but also how to reverse the effects of
his chemical accident while it may not
be the best thing King has ever made
it's at least entertaining for the most
part luckily the show is also supported
by one of the better casts to have
appeared in a Stephen King series to
Haven ran on Sci Fi for five seasons
between 2010 and 2015 which actually
makes it one of Stephen King's most
commercially successful TV series based
on the author's novel the Colorado kid
Haven follows FBI agent Audrey Parker as
she in
investigate supernatural occurrences
called the troubles in Haven Maine as
time goes on the show delves deeper into
Audrey's mysterious backstory as well as
the source of the troubles Haven took
some time to find its footing and its
first season was the lowest rated of its
five on Rotten Tomatoes
with the Critics consensus being that
the show was a derivative supernatural
crime procedural as time went on however
Haven improved shifting focus on to its
supernatural elements and character
developments rather than following the
standard police procedural formula the
show can go a little off the rails at
times but as a whole it works pretty
well
nightmares & dreamscapes from the
stories of Stephen King is an eight part
anthology series that ran on TNT in 2006
it's based mostly off Kings short story
collection of the same name and each
episode tells a completely different
tale with a completely different cast of
characters in true king fashion
nightmares & dreamscapes acts as a near
perfect representation of the author's
track record with small screen
adaptations some of the episodes are
good others are not the biggest problem
is that nightmares & dreamscapes tries
to do a little bit of everything which
perhaps explains why twines up finding
success only about half the time what it
does manage to do well however is bring
together a solid cast for each episode
and the presence of those cast tends to
make up for some of the show's weaker
storylines overall however nightmares &
dreamscapes only serves as a sad
reminder that you could be spending your
time watching a much better anthology
series in a perfect world Kingdom
hospital would have been a miniseries
instead it was stretched into a regular
TV show that still wound up lasting only
15 episodes it tells the story of a
bizarre staff and patients at Kingdom
Hospital in Lewiston Maine a place that
sits on the ruins of another recently
burned down Hospital the show gets
pretty crazy at times but it's also
genuinely creepy too by far the most
interesting thing about Kingdom Hospital
however is the fact that it's the first
adaptation Stephen King took on that
wasn't drawn from his own material in
fact the show was originally based on a
Danish TV movie by lars von trier
still King told the New York Times that
the show was the thing I like best out
of all the things I've done the mist
could have been a great show about human
nature and the horror that comes with
facing your deepest secrets instead it
goes way too far with its visual effects
and totally forgets that in order to
make an audience care about a character
that character has to be likeable I
think we should think less and pray more
in the case of the mist which only made
it to ten episodes before being
cancelled the characters are generally
pretty terrible people and they really
don't make it easy to root for them add
to that across-the-board mediocrity on
the part of the show's actors and the
result is a series that fails to live up
to the big-screen version that came a
few years before on the plus side the
mist does have one of the creepiest
settings of any Stephen King adaptation
the fictional Bridgeville main is a
beautiful and picturesque location that
morphs into a living nightmare for its
residents apart from that not much to
see here in 1999 ABC aired storm of the
century a three-part miniseries about
the residents of little tall island set
off the coast of Maine when a storm
rolls in that brings the town to a
complete standstill a mysterious and
deadly man named Andre Leno's approaches
the townspeople and promises not to harm
them for a price in a sinister twist
that price turns out to be one of the
families children storm of the century
is another of Stephen King's original
screenplays as opposed to an adapted
work and while it's a far more
successful attempt at the danger in the
weather theme than that portrayed by the
mist its failure lies and king's
inability to self edit there's really no
reason this particular story should have
been a three-part series if anything it
would have made a great feature film but
there's only so far you can go with the
story of a demonic man in search of a
protege especially when the bulk of
people involved in the story are pretty
one-dimensional background characters
under the dome has a fascinating premise
an entire town is suddenly blocked off
from the rest of the world by way of a
huge indestructible dome no one knows
where it came from
the gun
and can't get through it and resources
quickly start to dwindle
while there are sci-fi elements
obviously in place here under the dome
finds its most success on account of
Stephen King's ability to find monsters
in everyday people its first season was
certified fresh' on Rotten Tomatoes with
the Critics consensus being that the
show was an effective and engrossing
horror mystery with airtight plotting
and great special effects but unlike
other kings series under the dome lost
steam going into its second and third
seasons despite a number of twists and
turns in the story it just wasn't enough
story there to warrant the number of
years it stayed on the air like many of
Stephen King's stories the deadzone
begins with a car crash after waking up
from a six-year coma Jonny Smith
suddenly becomes able to see the past
and future of those he comes into
contact with as the deadzone progresses
Jonny becomes more involved with law
enforcement taking on an advisory role
of sorts to help solve crimes this was
in 2002 prior to Haven and so many other
supernatural crime dramas we see on TV
now so at the time the deadzone was a
fairly original concept add that to a
solid cast and the show winds up being a
pretty well-rounded endeavor for its
sixth season run if you were to flip on
the stand now there's a good chance you
wouldn't be able to make it through the
first episode the special effects in
this six hour miniseries are very very
bad firmly cementing it in time as a
product of early 90s television if you
can look past its dodgy effects however
the stand is a series that won't
disappoint the stand follows a journey
of a group of survivors in
post-apocalyptic America this series is
a long haul - it's a four-part
miniseries that completely lays out and
then resolves the battle for Humanity
but so is the Stephen King novel it's
based upon at over 1,100 pages the stand
is one of the author's longest books
ultimately the miniseries does the work
justice but it'll take a little
sacrifice on the viewers part to get
there in 2016
Stephen King teamed up with JJ Abrams to
bring his novel 11/22/63 to life the
resulting series which ran for 8
episodes on hulu tells the story of what
would
happen if someone prevented JFK's
assassination James Franco plays Jake
Epping a teacher who discovers a time
portal in the back room of his friend's
cafe I'm telling you you shouldn't be
here
well
I'm here as Jake attempts to change the
past the past pushes back against his
efforts and things get complicated when
he meets and falls for a woman named
Sadie not only is this a Stephen King
series that doesn't look like a cheap
made-for-tv movie but 11/22/63 is also
well acted and well-written
and it's eight episode length is exactly
the right amount of time to tell this
story without feeling like it's dragging
audiences into the abyss
everything that Stephen King does best
all comes together beautifully in the
little Maine town of Castle Rock in the
creepy Hulu show of the same name
Andre Holland plays Henry Matthew Deaver
a man who returns to his hometown two
decades after leaving having once been
suspected of killing his adopted father
during his stay he uncovers some
disturbing secrets buried by the town's
officials as well as the supernatural
forces behind them Castle Rock has ties
to the wider world of Kings written work
so fans will continually come across
hidden easter eggs and in Universe nods
but more importantly the series is just
really well done the cast is phenomenal
the production value is high and the
result is a genuinely frightening show
that has introduced new generations to
the twisty terrifying world of America's
greatest horror author mr. Mercedes
premiered on the audience network in
2017 the series tells the story of bill
Hodges a retired detective determined to
solve the case of mr. Mercedes a killer
who took the lives of 16 people at a
local job fair when mr. Mercedes sets
his sights on Hodges a dark and twisted
game of cat-and-mouse ensues the show
walks a fine line between police drama
mystery and horror and the further along
it gets into its narrative the more
sinister the plot becomes its premiere
season is certified fresh' on Rotten
Tomatoes with the Critics consensus
being that it propels it's tense creepy
narrative with quick-witted dialogue
strong characters and terrifying
surprises check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]